hello everyone it's seven o'clock and we
start this morning with a reported claim
from Prince Harry that he was physically
confronted by his brother William in a
row over his relationship with Meghan
Markle those allegations are made in a
leaked copy of his new book seen by The
Guardian newspaper we'll have all the
latest on that plus another day another
strike rail passengers are facing a
third day of significant disruption this
week with warnings that sways of the
country will have no trains running at
all as train drivers start their walk
out we'll be joined by the head of the
aslaf Union Mick Whelan and we'll also
hear from the rail delivery Group which
represents the train companies it's
Thursday the 5th of January
Prince Harry reportedly accuses his
brother William of a physical
confrontation over his relationship with
Meghan Markle in a leaked copy of his
book seen by The Guardian newspaper
the train drivers begin a fresh walk out
this morning the government is poised to
bring in anti-strike laws as early as
this week
passengers are warned of significant
disruption with no trains running in
some areas I'll bring you the latest
from Victoria Station
no longer the party of big spending
secure starmer to set out Labor's plans
in his first speech of the year
the funeral of Pope Benedict takes place
this morning presided over by his
successor
we'll be live from the Vatican where
tens of thousands of mourners are
gathering to pay their respects
online retail giant Amazon announces the
biggest round of layoffs in the
company's history
and in the U.S deadlock in Congress as
the Republicans failed for a sixth time
to elect a new house speaker
[Music]
hello a very good morning to you and a
warm welcome to Sky News breakfast well
Prince Harry has reportedly claimed that
he was physically confronted by his
brother William in a row over his
relationship with Meghan Markle well
those allegations are made an elite copy
of his new book which is set to be
published next week and seen by The
Guardian newspaper what's going to use
his approached Kensington Palace for a
response in the meantime let's talk to
our Royal correspondent Rhianna Mills
who joins me now so Rihanna some pretty
serious claims being reported today what
can you tell us about them
yeah so anticipation has really been
ramping up I think over the last few
months ahead of this book being released
we of course knew that the title was
going to be spare we've had that Netflix
docu-series and people have been
wondering exactly how far Prince Harry
would go uh when it came to to writing
down his Recollections and what he's
wanted to share but the the claims that
we're hearing from this leaked copy are
quite extraordinary when it comes to the
breakdown in the relationship that he
had with his brother now it's worth
saying that the book the review copies
aren't due out until Monday they're not
due to be released into the public until
Tuesday and yet the Guardians seem to
have had a copy in advance now I'll just
read you some of what it says in this
Guardian article in terms of this
altercation which it seems happened
while Prince Harry claims that happened
back in 2019 he says that it was all to
do with William basically calling Megan
abrasive rude and difficult he then
writes that William came into into their
home at Nottingham Cottage Harry gave
him a glass of water and said Willie I
can't speak to you when you're like this
Harry then writes he set down the water
called me another name then came at me
it all happened so fast so very fast he
grabbed me by the collar ripping my
necklace and he knocked me to the floor
I landed on the dogs bowl which cracked
under my back the pieces cutting into me
I lay there for a moment dazed then got
to my feet and told him to get out now
they are very serious allegations this
morning I have reached out to two people
at Kensington Palace for any comments so
far haven't heard anything back from
them we know that in 2019 that
relationship between the two brothers
was falling apart not simply because of
those leaked reports which Harry has
repeatedly talked about in the Netflix
documentary and these interviews that
are due to be released on Sunday with
likes of Anson Cooper for CBS and Tom
bradby for ITV
but also because Harry himself in a
documentary talked about how he wasn't
getting on with his brother so it's not
unexpected to hear that the brothers
were not getting on in 2019 but it is
shocking to be given this much personal
detail I think in the past there's been
criticisms of Harry that he's made some
some very damning allegations when it
comes to racism within the palace or
allegations that they weren't taking
Megan's mental health issues seriously
enough but there have been suggestions
that they haven't gone far enough in
naming specifics but it seems that Harry
in this book is not holding back
indeed Rhiannon thanks very much indeed
now huge parts of the country will once
again have no trains running today as
train drivers from the aslaf Union begin
their walkout and further strikes are
looming with the rmt set to Stage
another 48-hour strike on Friday and
Saturday well meanwhile the government
is expected to unfail new anti-strike
laws over the coming days well our
correspondent sabachoudry is at Victoria
Station for us this morning so example
what's the level of disruption that's
expected of four passengers today
thank you
good morning Bob just to give you a bit
of context before we start it is the ass
left train Union's sixth day of strike
action since last summer and today
around 12 and a half thousand uh train
drivers are expected to be walking out
which means that about 20 percent of
trains today won't be operated now
aslaf's leader Mick Whelan has said that
the cost of living crisis has
particularly hit his members hard and
that they feel that a pay increase is
long overdue and for this reason amongst
his members there is a vast will to be
in this he says for the Long Haul and
that his members feel they need to go
faster and harder in their strike action
to get their message heard and that
because of that uh it never Strike
action is likely to be inevitable at
Mick Whelan has said now this week
overall has been a tricky week for
commuters this is not the first strike
day that we've seen the rmt union this
week have two 48-hour strike days the
next one being on Friday and Saturday
and that is in a separate dispute about
pay about changes in terms and
conditions in contracts and also job
security when it comes to several
different roles now the overarching
message between the various groups
striking is is one in the same it's come
to the negotiating table here are
demands and the strikes will stop and
also in addition to that it's check
before you travel
always good advice thanks very much
indeed
now the labor leaders kirst armor will
set out his vision for a labor
government later on today in his first
speech of the year he's expected to say
that labor is no longer the party of big
spending vowing that he would not get
its big government checkbook out again
well this comes a day after Rishi sunak
made his own speech about priorities for
the year ahead so let's hear a little
bit more about all of this the shadow
Chancellor Rachel Reeves is with me now
so Rachel Reeves we're told that today's
speech from secure stama will be all
about what he stands for so what does
kiristama stand for
good morning Anna it's great to be on
your program this morning at Kia's
speech today we'll be setting out uh
some of the the vision for a labor
leadership and a labor government and
particularly focusing on the fact that
our country seems to Lurch from crisis
to crisis with sticking plaster policies
to paper over the cracks rather than
addressing some of the long-term
challenges that we face as a country and
that is what Kira is determined to do as
our next prime minister to actually get
a grip of some of the long-term
underlying problems with our health
service with our economy with our energy
Supply and so much more to put us on a
thermo footing to make us more resilient
and more secure as a society and as an
economy to face into the big challenges
and Kira and myself runs a No Illusion
about the scale of the challenges that
we will inherit so a big set of
challenges but we are ambitious for the
country we see so much potential and we
want to unleash that to to Really secure
better public services and also
improvements in living standards that
frankly people haven't seen for a decade
or more
well the government Richie sunak would
no doubt say that they're also tackling
those long-term challenges and just
yesterday we heard from the Prime
Minister didn't we he says he's putting
forward some concrete promises on that
front those five pledges on debt jobs
waiting lists and small boats the things
that he says are people's main
priorities are those labor priorities
too
well look everybody wants to see
um waiting lists come down Small Boat
Crossings uh uh end but the the Prime
Minister yesterday uh has announced a
set of
um Ambitions to fix the problems that
him and his government have created and
then wants the public to give him the
credit for doing that I just don't think
it washes the conservatives have had 13
years now and the question that people
will be asking is uh my family and me
better off after 13 years of
conservative government are our public
services our schools and our hospitals
are better run and in better condition
than they were 13 years ago and frankly
is anything in our country working
better than it was when the
conservatives came to power and I think
the answer to those questions is no and
that's why people are turning away from
the conservatives and looking again at
Labor and for the first time in quite a
long time I think labor can look to the
country knowing that we have the answers
the fully costed and funded policies to
address some of the long-term big
challenges that we face as a country and
give people some hope back and some
belief back that things can be better
than the mess that we've been in these
last few years
okay you want to give people hope back
the last time we heard from kirstama was
a speech with Gordon Brown on Devolution
which may be important but it may not
necessarily be something you put on a
pledge card it may not be something that
may give people hope so are we going to
get new policies today
well look when I'm in in my constituency
in Leeds and I'll be there uh this
evening when I travel around the country
people have huge ambition and pride in
their communities and they want a
government that matches that ambition
and that Pride but also empowers local
people and Community to take decisions
on their behalf rather than always
having to come cap in hand to the
government to ask them for money and for
support and resources to to to power
their communities we want to give power
to local people and local communities to
make decisions on their own behalf to
realize the potential of their
communities and that's why the plans
that KIA put forward at the end of last
year to devolve more power to give away
more power to to Regions and Nations and
communities across Britain it is so
exciting because For the first time in a
long time local people will be able to
make decisions on their behalf rather
than having into US government to be
able to do things whether it's on buses
or trains or transport or energy or
housing actually make those decisions
for themselves okay so we're going to
hear more about Devolution is what
you're saying what about new policies
will we get anything new from kirst
armor today
well look you'll you hear the speech and
Care we'll set that out but the key
theme in the speech today is that we
need to tackle the long-term challenges
that our country faces because while
every country in the world has been
exposed to shocks from covid to Russia's
invasion of Ukraine we in Britain have
been uniquely exposed we ran down our
Health Service we ran down our PPE
supplies and so we were ill prepared for
the covid pandemic but we got rid of our
gas storage we banned on short wind and
we stopped our home insulation program
which meant that we were exposed to
increases in gas and electricity prices
we can't keep lurching from crisis to
crisis we need Labor's green Prosperity
plan to ensure that we have energy
security and Independence while keeping
prices low we need to reform our health
service but also resource it properly
with one of the biggest expansions of
the workforce in history funded by
getting rid of the non-dom tax status so
that we can afford more doctors and
nurses and midwives than health visitors
those are just some of the policies that
labor will be setting out in more detail
over the next year that can make us
stronger as an economy stronger as a
society more resilient to the shocks
that face not just Britain but around
the world but for which Britain has been
particularly exposed to because of the
neglect from the conservatives
so you want to boost the number of
doctors you say you're going to fund
that from Banning London status but what
about day-to-day spending on the NHS
kirstama we're told will say that his
pledges shouldn't be taken as code for
getting the checkbook out so does that
mean that the NHS will get no more money
beyond what was promised in the Autumn
statement
well we've set out how we would get rid
of the non-dom tax status which costs
3.2 billion pounds a year and we would
plow that money into training more
doctors and nurses because one of the
big problems that we've got is of
retention and recruitment in our
National Health Service which means
every day of the week not just when
there's industrial action it's a real
challenge to get that doctor's
appointment to be seen at a e to get an
ambulance when you need it and get a bed
in a hospital and so we've committed to
that expansion of doubling the number of
places every year at medical school as
well as expansions of Midwife District
nurses and nurses training places as
well to uh to and we know that these
things won't happen overnight and we
know that it takes time to train doctors
and nurses but under labor the Cavalry
is coming we will invest in the
workforce in the NHS we also know that
more is needed this winter and if we
were in power to day we would be doing
more to ensure that people could be
discharged from hospital because our
social care system would be working uh
better we'll be reforming doctors
pensions so that doctors aren't taking
early retirement because it just doesn't
Stack Up financially for them to
continue
um at work we would introduce Fair pay
agreements for our social care sector to
help Recruitment and Retention there and
we would launch a Jabs Army to uh to to
get people to be administering as we had
during the covid pandemic the Jabs for
covid and flu to help people ensure that
they're properly protected through these
winter months because we know more and
more beds are being taken up in our
hospitals because of people with flu and
covered so we need to make sure that
that vaccination program for both flu
and covet are being properly rolled out
but look it's really important that
every policy that labor puts forward is
fully costed and fully funded it's what
the electorate expect from us and it
shows a respect for the Etc that we show
where the money is going to come from
and every line in our Manifesto will be
fully costed and fully funded we've said
that we would get rid of the non-dom tax
status and use that to fund our National
Health Service I think that's the right
priority for our economy and for our
country
okay Rachel Reese we appreciate your
time this morning thanks so much
thanks
so our political correspondents Tamara
Cohen is with me now so another day
another big speech at this time uh
secure starmer laying out at what it
means at what a labor government might
look like how much have we learned from
Rachel Reeves this morning about that do
you think well these are going to be
really by the end of today we'll see the
Contours of the next election we had
Rishi sooner yesterday who of course
became prime minister and very chaotic
circumstances for the first time saying
this is what I'm about I've got these
five pledges some of them a lot easier
to deliver than others three of them on
the economy small boats and NHS waiting
lists and saying in two years Ola made
some progress on all of them he says
kirstarma obviously been party leader
for a lot longer but a lot of it was
during covid he's had these internal
battles with his party which are ongoing
I mean this speech is very much designed
to say the era of Jeremy corbyn is over
the era of big spending we're not going
to spend our way out of this mess is
what he'll say so what do you do about
the big challenges like the NHS like
these public sector strikes like the
cost of living in people's energy bills
if you're not going to spend a lot more
money well that's going to be what he's
challenged on you can see that Rishi
CNAC has very much tried to make strikes
and standing up for discipline with
spending a key dividing line how will
kirstama respond to that and will he be
able to connect with the public in tell
the public about his values as we heard
a bit from Rishi sunak yesterday in a
way which makes them of course labor are
20 points ahead in the polls but will
they see him as a future Prime Minister
today that will be the challenge I think
sometimes labor have focused on some of
the very important long-term issues but
has he got anything really voter
friendly to offer people immediately
yeah but interesting one to watch
tomorrow thanks very much indeed
well the funeral for Pope Benedict XVI
will be held at the Vatican this morning
making history as it's presided over by
the current pope Pope Francis
well our Europe correspondent Adam
Parsons joins us now from Vatican City
So Adam tell us a little bit about what
we can expect later on this morning then
well for Assad it is a pretty chilly
Misty rather evocative day here in
Vatican City and thousands upon
thousands of people are pouring into
this tiny city state for an occasion
that is in a sense unprecedented
certainly in modern times because this
funeral of the Pope embaratus Benedict
XVI will be presided over by the present
Pope uh Pope Francis
and this is the first time this has
happened for for many hundreds uh of
years it's nearly 600 years since a pope
resigned from the job a couple of
hundred years ago we did have a funeral
conducted by Pope for a predecessor but
that was uh they've been a long Gap this
is something very unusual because of
course Benedict spent the rest of his
life after retirement living here in the
Vatican almost in the shadow of his
successor and I think in death as much
as in life that question of his
resignation of his retirement from the
realm will linger over the surface and
all of the questions it raises some of
them still
unresolved as for what we're going to
see well the the order of service goes
on for 37 Pages it's going to take a
couple of hours starting in just over an
hour's time from now and the nature of
it will be very similar to that of a
funeral service for an incumbent but not
identical and that has been in a way the
theme throughout the lying in state of
Pope Benedict Was similar to that that
will be organized for an incumbent Pope
but also slightly different he wasn't
wearing the full papal vestments as he
laid in state although he was holding
rosary beads but those will be added
into the coffin alongside some coins and
also a document written in Latin
outlining the achievements of his papacy
as is traditional with popes will be
buried in three coffins a cedar wood
coffin originally then surrounded by
zinc coffin and then a further wooden
coffin and after the service which will
be led by Francis who will deliver that
service we understand while while
sitting in a wheelchair he uh Benedict
will be buried beneath some Peter's
Basilica in the Tomb previously occupied
by his predecessor John Paul II and the
focus then will be on how the death of
Benedict changes the papacy of Pope
Francis and whether he may yet follow
that precedent with his own retirement
Adam thanks very much indeed and just to
let you know that we will have full
coverage of the Pope's funeral later on
this morning with the service due to
begin at around 8 30.
in the meantime do stay with us they'll
come here on the show I'm going to be
joined by the General Secretary of the
aslef Union MC wheelan as passengers
face a third consecutive day of travel
disruption this week
chair of the rail delivery group and
managing director of first rail Steve
Montgomery will be also joining me to
discuss the long-running dispute over
pay for rail staff
[Music]
that's coming up very shortly first
though let's take a look at some of the
day's other headlines and Amazon intends
to cut more than 18 000 job roles as
part of a Workforce reduction strategy
according to its chief executive Andy
jassi says the carts which amount to six
percent of its corporate Workforce will
mostly impact the company's e-commerce
and Human Resources departments
the man suspected of stabbing to death
for University students in their beds
has arrived in Idaho to face murder
charges after he voluntarily agreed to
be extradited from Pennsylvania 28 year
old Brian coburger is alleged to have
killed housemates in November last year
Mr coburger denies murder
new car registrations have fallen to
their lowest level since 1992 due to
global supply chain issues and shortages
that's according to the Society of motor
manufacturers and Traders which says
around one points
1.61 million new cars were registered in
2022 that's down two percent from the
year before
I wasn't just flying from mainland China
to England will need to take a covid-19
test before departure from today the
European Union has also strongly
encouraged its member states to impose
testing China has seen a surging cases
since relaxing its zero covered policy
at the end of last year
so let's get the latest on our top story
today and the continuing strikes are
going on today's strike is being called
by the aslef union and I'm joined Now by
Mick Whelan who's the general secretary
so very good morning to you thanks so
much for coming in so today's action
will be the driver's sixth coordinated
uh day of strike action since last
summer have you made any progress with
either the rail companies or the
governments in that time very little
it's been a long on game process I've
attended every negotiation personally
and I think we're as far away now as we
were at the start unfortunately there
have been some newspaper reports today
that have suggested that the government
might be on the brink of offering
workers a new pay deal the suggestion is
it would be worth around 2 000 pounds a
year have you heard anything on those
lines well it's nice that they tell the
newspapers and the media before they
tell us no the people that have actually
been in the talks
um I know obviously we'd like to know
what strings go with it I mean as we
enter 2023 this is the fourth year
without pay rise and we'd normally we
get this time of year getting ready to
go into pay talks of 2023 and we've seen
inflation during a period of time run at
14 uh in double digits this year so the
figures that have been spoke about don't
really put a dent in the cost of living
crisis so if that was was offered to you
would she reject it I'd have to have a
look at it first I mean the idea that
people float stuff and then you're asked
whether you're accepted or not without
seeing the details and strings that go
with it it's very very difficult to come
in on
ethical do you think it is to get public
on the public on board when you're
talking about pay because there might be
some people that say train drivers are
paid quite well aren't they I think
looking at some of the figures train
drivers earn an average of around 48 500
pounds starting salary is around thirty
thousand they might say nurses for
example are paid a lot less well I think
nurses level we have I believe the fire
brigade and public sectors workers I
believe that teachers and Vocational
staffs to have what we have but I've
never been quite the game of politics
and envy nobody's actually ever given us
anything over the course of
privatization we've given massive
productivity and flexibility to generate
what we've got and this idea then that
we shouldn't have a pay rise for 10
years to allow other people that are
underpaid to catch up with this is quite
not one we subscribe to what about how
these negotiations negotiations have
been carried out there are also some
suggestions around that the government
is is looking to try to strike a deal
with the rmt in that in with aslaf
rather in a bid to isolate the rmt have
you heard anything about that do you see
I saw it in the papers yesterday and
it's nonsense we won't do that I mean it
we have our strike and we're doing what
we're doing I've got great Praise My
comrades and colleagues in the rmt who
find an existential battle well they
want to take away 50 of people's jobs
and degrade what's left and I think
would if the government gets away what
it's doing we'll be left with an
inherently unsafe Railway system we'll
have other problems
um our problem is that we work for 15
privatized companies that we'll strike
with today and they've done a rather
corrupt deal with the government that
won't allow pay rise to take place all
the talks take place through free
Collective buying which they should do
but what about the government's argument
that there isn't a bottomless pet of
money they can't necessarily afford to
pay everybody who's asking for pay Rises
what they're asking for so we didn't
seek a pay rise during the pandemic and
we went to work
um during that period of time the people
we worked for made 500 million pound in
profits
um if you look at company's house and
the pay rise as directors the dividends
that have been paid and profits made by
the rail operating companies it seems
that weight is no longer part of their
fixed costs that they can pay a
dividends their shareholders out of the
taxpayers purse but the people actually
generate those dividends don't get a
share
it's a frustrating time for passengers
isn't it look I'd much rather be talking
to you about a green agenda I'd like to
talk about safer Railways investment
growing Railways like go back to my day
job if I'm honest but we are where we
are and you know if we don't raise our
issues and articulate our voice no one's
listened to us I wouldn't be on here
today unless we were on strike well the
government's clearly feels that
passengers are frustrated they're
talking about new anti-strike
legislation aren't they they're talking
about minimum service guarantees there's
some suggestion around that that could
even potentially mean that strikes could
be deemed illegal if unions refuse to
provide that minimum level of service
what do you make of those reports well
we already have the most Draconian and
authoritarian strike laws and Trade
Union laws in Europe only the one you
had worst and I think more recently with
the trade Union bill we actually outdid
them we have seen our counterparts in
Europe introduced minimum strike levels
that are unworkable the idea then that
in companies that don't fully employ
enough people that people could be
forced come to work when they
legitimately illegally should be on
strike could be difficult to see how it
could be done but we'll look at the
detail of those laws if we have to
comply with them we will it's more
likely to lead to longer strife and a
different form of action because there
will be a knock-on effect by anything
that happens
and would you consider taking legal
action against the government if a
policy like that were to be introduced
we're currently with 11 other trade
unions taking legal action against the
last set of laws they put in place and
we would look at doing that in future as
well
looking at some of the figures they're
quite startling this week aren't they
about the amount of money that that
people are losing from the hospitality
sector for example because of rail
strikes doesn't there have to be some
sort of minimum service to allow people
to run their businesses allow people to
go to work well the real problems and
Logistics of the railways trains run
rounds being the right places for the
Peaks
um minimum service levels that
subsequently got negotiated on Company
by company basis when you look at
something that's complex in the
connectivity of the Railway to my mind
is unworkable and at what point does it
become unsafe what would the level be
would it be 20 with 30 was the only way
to run a safe Railway be 100 and take
away the right to strike totally what
sort of democracy are we aiming for
Richardson like I said is door is always
open to the negotiations when do you
next expect to have talks with the
government and with the Royal companies
I met with the transport Minister and
the rail Minister before Christmas and
they dropped me a note saying that the
rail minister is now going to be
facilitating the talks I meet with the
rail Minister on Monday I'm hoping
shortly after that we get back into a
round where we had a effectual talks and
can resolve the situation you said
you're in it for Long Haul though how
long do you think this could go on well
when you're asked the question about how
long will you do something for you do to
find a resolution so it has to be long
haul it will do I was also ask the
question will there be more strikes and
I said that um we've just reinforced all
their mandates now people are saying we
should go harder and faster now we
haven't done that yet okay we'll meet
Whelan we appreciate you coming in I
imagine you're going down to the picket
line now are you I've got one or two
media things to do that I'm on the picky
line at Houston and King cross thank you
okay thanks very much indeed for your
time
so the chat of the rail delivery group
Steve Montgomery is going to be on the
show as well to discuss that
long-running dispute overpay and working
conditions for real staff as well he's
coming on a little bit later so do stay
with us for that
foreign
[Music]
welcome back we're going to turn our
attention to the US now and despite
multiple rounds of voting the Republican
party has once again been unable to
elect Kevin McCarthy who served as the
majority leader for the last four years
as the next Speaker of the House of
Representatives despite winning a narrow
majority in November's elections the
Republicans have now failed six times to
elect a speaker that's the first time in
a hundred years that the house has been
unable to agree on a candidate from
Washington our U.S correspondent Mark
Stone reports
they gathered for a second day with the
chair they need to fill still empty the
engine room of the American Democratic
machine is rudderless unable to choose
its leader Madam clerk I Rise to
nominate Hakeem Jeffries as Speaker of
the House Kevin McCarthy for Speaker of
the House Byron Donalds for Speaker of
the House of Representatives
to find a mess comparable to this you'd
need to go back a century it's all about
this man Kevin McCarthy the Republican
leader of a house that now has a
republican majority so he should be the
speaker but beyond the backpacks it
hasn't quite gone to plan the gentleman
is recognized for a second day his
allies nominated him
but again he fell short of the votes
it's only week one of the Year an
American political drama is in full
swing this is about more than just the
messy mechanics of democracy because it
is exposing the deep deep divisions
within just one party the Republican
party's majority is so narrow that they
can't even get this legislative session
open until they literally get their
house in order American democracy is
stalled the smiles for the cameras he
knows are on him mask the embarrassment
Jeffries Moore voted for the minority
Democratic leader that voted for him on
the other side of the chamber the
Republican Rebels plotted their next
move and yet the man they'd naturally
follow Donald Trump is backing the man
they won't McCarthy even his caps locked
command hasn't pulled them into line
among the rebels Congressman Bob good
we're going to resolve this in a few
hours or a few days or even a couple of
weeks but we will live with this
decision for two years before the next
election and folks aren't going to be
voting in the next election based on how
long it took for us to choose a speaker
down Pennsylvania Avenue at the White
House a president aware of the look it's
not a good thing it's the United States
of America and I hope they get their act
together and what's going to happen we
are learning plenty through all this yes
American politics is in An Almighty mess
and yes the power of trump it does seem
to be waning but beyond all that one of
the two parties dominating politics here
is so fractured it's paralyzing the
political process the speaker's chair
still empty Mark Stone Sky News in
Washington
so commuters are suffering with a third
consecutive day of travel disruption
this week as members of aslef at 15 rail
operators have walked out overpay
disputes meanwhile the government is
also preparing to unveil new anti-strike
laws in the coming days which could
allow it to take legal action against
unions over striking members
well earlier I spoke to the General
Secretary of azlef Mick Whelan had asked
his reaction
we already have the most Draconian and
authoritarian strike laws and Trade
Union laws in Europe only Lithuania had
worst and I think more recently with the
trade Union bill we actually outdid them
we have seen our counterparts in Europe
introduce minimum strike levels that are
unworkable the idea then that in
companies that don't fully employ enough
people that people could be forced to
come to work when they legitimately
illegally should be on strike could be
difficult to see how it could be done
but we'll look at the detail of those
laws if we have to comply with them we
will it's more likely to lead to longer
strife and a different form of action
because there will be a knock-on effect
by anything that happens
well with me now is the chair of the
rail delivery group Steve Montgomery
very good morning to you thanks so much
for talking to us let's start on that
news that the government's poised to
announce legislation to to curb the
right to strike and enforce minimum
service levels uh is thought to be in
six areas including rail is that
something that you'd welcome
I think it's something for a government
to decide what they want to do with it
obviously clear with the level of
disruption that they're seen on the real
industry in particular has been quite
significant and has obviously impacted
on a lot of people's daily lives so
again we haven't seen the legislation
yet we don't understand the full uh
elements of it until we get that then
we'll look at it and see how we can
apply it once it's passed obviously
through a whatever method government
wants to put it through it so there's a
bit of work to be done to be fully
understand it at this moment well yes
you're right we do need to wait for more
detail but mcwheelan suggested that this
minimum service legislation could be
unworkable and could even drive a
further wedge between the unions and the
rail companies what do you think do you
think this could make things worse
I think we have to be into what the
legislation says you know I really at
this one time it's difficult to really
give a straight answer here I think
obviously any further legislation is
always something that people will
Challenge and but again we've got an
industry particularly the real industry
with a champion to talk about that has
been through significant pain at this
long time and its customers are
suffering really badly and none of us
want to see that what we want to do is
try and get these disputes resolved and
make sure that you've got a service that
we can be proud of to give it to
customers and at the moment it's not a
great place to be in for the staff for
management for the stakeholders and the
trade unions don't like to be in this
position either so we've got to try and
resolve the dispute that we're in at the
moment
your disputes of course with um aslef
and rmt the rail companies are
continuing discussions with both of
those unions and I spoke to Mick Whelan
from azlev just a short time ago he said
once again that uh his workers haven't
seen a pay rise since 2019. so are you
going to give them one
we want to get people up here in case
um again the industry we have to
understand that the industry is probably
20 of Revenue a little bit it was in
2019 staff have noted appearances from
them we've been talking to the trade
unions and we we do genuinely want to
give people a pay increase but we need
to reform the industry can keep taking
lots of taxpayers money we're roughly
about 175 million pounds per month in
Lost Revenue so what were you saying to
the trade unions is what what is
bringing sensible areas of reform that
we can then use some of that money to go
and get people up here increase we can't
just keep taking taxpayers money there's
obviously other competing sectors
whether it's the education NHS
military all those different sectors are
all looking for additional money and the
real industry has to go and cut its own
Claude And I think with sensible reform
we can look at how we can self-fund a
pay deal but we need to trade unions to
work with us in that area
well yes and you're in dispute with the
rmt as well Network rail in a separate
dispute so they think they're within
touching distance of a deal with them
they think they can talk union members
round to an offer to train companies
think that they can talk the rmt round
or is it months of more strikes
no I think we have closer and we'll get
more work to do with the rmt I I think
but I do think we are closer than we've
been in a long time we just need to get
back around the table and keep talking
sensibly and I think we are in a better
place and we're probably been in the
last number of months but we'll get a
bit of work cell to do with that empty
and Lynch made a specific claim to us
this week that you were close to a deal
but it was scuppered by the Department
of Transport he put in Clauses insisting
on a driver-only operation which
infuriated their members what do you say
to that is that true
I think you know we've always had driver
on the operation was in the original
mandate that we had with our MTN for
government and we're working through
that we can see out of different ways we
can do things so it's really important
that we people understand that you know
we'll get an industry for your driver
only operation is already in use in a
large number of services so it's not
something new that we're trying to bring
on to the table and but a lot of this
reform whether it's asleep whether it's
rmt it's actually carried out in some
companies but not in other companies so
we'll just try to get standardization
it's not about asking people to work
longer uh you know most drivers at a 35
hour weaker average of a 35 hour a week
um we're not asking people to work
longer to take pay cuts what we'll try
to do is get people to work within that
35 or a bit more productive and that's
not going to cost them do anything you
know that that can help us wouldn't
appear increased on staff I admit that
really will be more sustainable for the
long term and that's what we're looking
to try and do and it's not myself the
reform that's going to you know the
people working the full 35 hours you
know we're trained driving particularly
we've got to take any again any account
safety so it's really sensible reform
that we're looking for that can then
allow us to then fund a pay increase
well Steve Montgomery chairman of the
rail delivery group we appreciate your
time this morning thanks very much
indeed thank you
now we're going to return now to our
coverage of Pope Benedict's funeral
which gets underway shortly with the
main service being led by his successor
Pope Francis let's show you the scene
while I bring in a sky events
commentator Alistair Bruce who's here
with me now welcome Alistair
um what can we expect today
well it's a very normal Roman Catholic
mass for the dead and it's a reflective
service
it is an opportunity for
all Catholics to reflect upon someone
who led their church for quite a period
and who has been present since in this
extraordinarily unique way of having
abdicated the highest role in the Church
of Rome and I think that what we will
see is a very reflective very peaceful
and immensely beautiful service in the
most extraordinary setting of Saint
Peter's Square in the heart of the
Vatican City at Rome
and how different will it be from the
kind of funeral you would normally
expect for a pope will it be very
similar even though this is a pope who'd
resigned
well a little bit different in that
normally
when a pope who is reigning dies there
then is a period called the empty seat
vacante where the Cardinals who gather
wait to decide who amongst them will
become the next Pope because we had the
abdication from the role by Pope
Benedict XVI he has been living in the
Vatican since Pope Francis was appointed
and they have worked as it were not
together but
Pope Benedict has been able to carry on
his researches and his prayer while Pope
Francis has led the church in Benedict
the 16th Place and so it's Unique that
we'll have a pope celebrating the mass
at the funeral of Secrets of his of his
predecessor so a really unusual moment
that in itself yes and and Benedict XVI
had led
the funeral mass for John Paul II so and
I think it's interesting that Benedict
XVI has asked to be interred
Anderson pieces exactly where his
predecessor John Paul II was placed
before he was brought up to the main
Saint Peter's Basilica because he was
beatified which Roman Catholics do if
they wish to choose someone who has
behaved so perfectly both in life and
afterwards in the ability to create
Miracles and so I think that you know
continues this story and for people who
aren't Christian or who aren't Roman
Catholic I think it'll be an opportunity
to understand the faith and see carried
out this moment that has meant so much
to Christians in Europe throughout the
centuries back to Saint Peter who was as
it were the first pope who was one of
the Disciples of Jesus Christ and as our
dates come from that time we know pretty
much exactly how long ago that was which
is
2023 years so a big moment for the Roman
Catholic church and and for those who
follow its Faith around the world what
about personally for Pope Francis I mean
what was his relationship like with Pope
Benedict given that they existed close
together for many recent years
well it can be very difficult can't it
when you take over a role and the person
who had it before you is still around
but under the 16th recognized
perhaps for health reasons that we will
get more information about later on that
that he really was not able to carry on
being the head of the church so he
stepped back and he said when he stepped
away from the office that he would
entirely do so and he has fulfilled that
completely I think in support of his
successor but I'm sure that it's also
quite nice if you're in this lonely
place of leadership to be able to go and
have a chat with someone
in the way that certainly in the past
Reign Prime Ministers were able to go
and talk to the queen who was a
continuing presence I think to an extent
maybe Pope Francis has found that very
reassuring but as we look into Saint
Peter's now and
all the congregation are gathering there
is an enormous number of cons
celebratory which means people are going
to be helping with the celebration of
the mass
Cardinals over a hundred of them
Bishops and Priests who will help Pope
Francis in the leading of this funeral
mass
and they had quite a different style as
popes didn't they what will the tone of
this service be well it very much
reflect Pope Benedict's style well I
think the point where we will get that
reflection will be in the homily which
is which is like a an address that's
given by the pope to better help people
understand the moment of the breaking of
bread and wine which is what Jesus
Christ set as an example to all Roman
Catholics and Christians so when he
explains and prepares people for that he
will have a chance to reflect upon the
man who was Pope Benedict XVI who was
Joseph ratzinger the Archbishop and
Cardinal from Germany who had been born
in a time of challenge for Germany so I
think
I think it will be very interesting to
hear what Francis says and I think he's
always been very very affectionate about
his predecessor I mean you know exactly
how he will prepare the congregation for
this moment and after all for Christians
death is a celebration in its own way of
moving to eternal life so if you are
Christian and believe that then it is a
very Moving Service that we're going to
witness today well yes and describe the
scene to us Alistair because we are
expecting tens of thousands of people to
to arrive in Rome who are amongst the
attendees and and what's likely to
happen
well the procession is now bringing Pope
Benedict XVI
the Emeritus Pope who resigned from
office from
Saint Peter's Basilica out to rest on
the steps
and for all those present it is a signal
of the beginning of the act of worship
and when he is placed on the steps
everyone will take their places for a
period of reflection
and in due course Pope Francis will take
his seat
and the
purpose of this process is to have that
period of reflection but coming out
from some pieces into this extraordinary
impressive Square created by berlini's
unfolding arms of the pillared sides and
also at the center of
the square will be
the great pillar that we believe
witnessed
the crucifixion of Saint Peter
who was Christ's first head of the
church back at the beginning of the
Christian Church itself
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
we prepare to celebrate mass by praying
the Holy Rosary together
Rosario
[Music]
Patrice the feeling is amen
foreign
first joyful mystery the agony of in the
garden
Premier Mysterio doloroso Laura
hello
[Music]
Domino's
the large congregation expected to be
about
30 000 today in Saint Peter Square I'm
being invited
is a preparatory tradition a chance for
all Roman Catholics to reflect upon
their faith
and the mass that is to come
you have many of the Cardinals and
archbishops and Bishops of the Rome
Catholic Church have gathered many
priests who wearing their white elves
and their stalls the red stalls over
their shoulders
and the service will begin in due course
but the
late
hope Emeritus has been placed in his
Cyprus coffin
at the heart of this gathered
congregation
Place Aid such as Archbishop George
ganswein who was his long-term private
secretary present
been with him since Pope Benedict as
Cardinal was the prefect that is the
head of the congregation of the doctrine
of faith
which was part of the curia which is the
government
of the grand Catholic Church in Rome
yes
[Music]
yes
Gloria Patriots
we can see the chair where Pope Francis
will celebrate the funeral mass
his predecessor who in that very simple
coffin
rests ready for that
funeral service to begin discouraging at
the pillar
Segundo Mysterio
[Music]
the scripture laid out in an open book
and also
the rosary that was used by paper
Meritus Benedict XVI
The Mists of Rome have closed in over
the Dome of the Basilica here
and the camera passes by the base of
that great pillar
known as the Silent Witness
which had been at the center of the
Coliseum in Rome
in ancient times when Saint Peter was
brought to that Coliseum
and crucified
ability to Spruce Ventures yes
the
16th will begin
at half past eight local time but until
that time
join with those who are here in St
Peter's Square in reflection and
preparation for the funeral of Pope
Benedict XVI
thanks very much indeed and will return
very shortly to Saint Peter's Square in
Rome is